foreign
for the Poetics of everyday language
began at 5 p.m on Saturdays
Amaya wella's dining room
at a table full of loud Unstoppable
women
my five aunts plus my mom's five aunts
old smoking some in their bras some in
the rulers all complaining about the
ineptitude of their husbands or the
rising prices at the grocery store
some use grand gestures pointing with
their mouths
others made up words
some yelled some cried
they were all narrating a similar
experience but each one of them put her
own twist to her Story Each one used a
different word choice a different rhythm
my mom complained in silence shaking her
head and sighing
energized curse words
you would say that good for nothing son
of a
my great aunt shot her eyes drank coffee
and pointed at God
the osito
what is wrong with this man
each one putting a different tune a
different music to her story
as a kid among them in ah marble how
elastic how expansive how infinite
language felt at the dining table how
fun
if my aunts didn't know a word they
would just make it up laugh about it and
stick it to the husband's nicknames
the word would then be tossed around and
eventually become part of her intimate
familiar vocabulary
my family is originally from the coast
of Colombia which is a region known for
its magnificent storytellers it's Grand
words a region where made up words are
the norm where music and Rhythm are
essential to speaking
I inherit the creative tongue from my
arms
in Colombia was a loud energized sucker
I wouldn't shut up I made up words too
but the moment I moved to the states and
landed in Miami all that energy and love
for language disappeared
it was here that I had my first
encounter with language hierarchy
I was 15 years old and we were reading
Romeo and Juliet in English class I
begged and prayed that I wouldn't be
called to read Juliet's part because it
was long and I didn't know what most of
the words meant
of course I would cause the real its
part
my heart sank
when I said I didn't want to the teacher
responded I would lose participation
point if I didn't
okay
I had to read it
I tried to push my tongue in impossible
ways try to Echo the sound that I have
been listening around me
but I butchered all the words
everyone around me laughed and the
teacher just stood there silently
I remember clenching that desk wanting
to disappear wishing to be made small
invisible
I went home that day and told my mom I
wasn't going back to school the laughter
and ridicule in school created deep fear
and anxiety inside me
I spoke differently and this clearly was
wrong
it started me that I couldn't access
that part of myself that was so excited
about language because my way of
speaking with an accent or inventing
words or pronouncing words as I heard
them was deemed wrong
I said son's giving instead of
Thanksgiving
I mix both languages I have to plan
child give me the Trap monster chances
ready
I remember staying up late to practice
pronouncing words but the kids at school
were to make fun of me
I hated myself for not fitting it not
realizing that there was a hierarchy
much bigger than me at play here I felt
I was the one who was wrong
and it wasn't only me who was being
correct and laughed at
I said teachers correct some of my peers
usually anyone who wasn't white shaming
immigrant kids for saying quora instead
of quarter
instead of peanut butter
conflate instead of corn flakes
it's in all of us were crossing an
invisible language boundary a boundary
policed by the teacher maintained by the
student's laughter
now let's take a step back and see
what's really happening here we tend to
think of language in this case English
as a closed Circle where all of us
English speakers exist
a closed Circle where correct English is
elevated at the center
when someone says something in another
language we know it is outside of that
Circle
when someone speaks English with an
accent or without proper grammar we know
it is inside the circle but not correct
not at the center
so we push both the language and the
people who speak it to the margins
we really don't consider how looking at
language as a closed circle with a solid
Center excludes so many people so many
ways of speaking and making sense of the
world
how this in turn creates a hierarchy of
language
I learned about how this hierarchy
isolates people the hard way by watching
the condescension of cashiers at the
grocery store every time my mom wouldn't
pronounce things right
by watching my mother shrink at every
joke at her mispronunciation until she
starts trying to speak English all
together and we just sit quietly in
shame
my mother who back in Colombia will call
the manager the owner if needed when her
coupons wouldn't scan because this Rises
two for once Angelita says right here
manager
I can still see her hand on hips
negating with her head articulating like
homegirl got a degree in bargaining
studies
my mom the discounts Queen will not
leave until she felt Justice was served
between coupons and rice
proudly bragged her sisters about her
later over coffee
I walked alongside her with a warm
grounding feeling
my mom could take anyone
then we moved to the states her sense of
being a valued human being the serving
of respect was destroyed by ridicule and
condescension
as I slowly became aware of this
hierarchy I realized that my mom my
sister my friends and me we were all
close to the bottom we were in the
margins of this circle and therefore of
society we couldn't reach the center
because of our ethnic and cultural
background
we sat in shame because our way of
speaking wasn't as refined
I realized also that this hierarchy
permeates all spaces and it's a
gatekeeper when it comes to accessing
resources and opportunities
I wasn't higher on several jobs because
I couldn't speak correct English the
manager is letting me know we're just a
little worried the customers won't
understand you
my writing also having me published in
many places because it mixes both
languages and this has seen as less than
not pure
my writing has been ridiculed in many
academic workshops was several times
white writers have made fun of my use of
Spanglish out loud rereading the text
for all to hear questioning is
legitimacy as real literature
my abilities as a student a worker my
value as a human being has been
questioned over and over again
and yet
there's Beauty and connection in this
marginal spaces for people in the
margins language creates cohesion
between us that different way of
speaking is a secret door only some of
us have access to
a door to an underworld of language
freedom
this world begins for me not in Miami
but in the former Esta Noche gay Latino
bar here in San Francisco
[Applause]
ten years ago I moved to San Francisco
in search of my freak tribe and found
the queenas talked in a dingy bar on
16th Street ironing their wigs and
filling up their bras
Ina it's a blend between Queen and Reina
Spanish for queen queen
that I learned about the long history of
LGBT people creating new words to
reflect our own histories our own
realities
it was here that my passion for language
bloomed again
The Story begins with the words
fears perra sisi Marica come here Butch
Papi
here
Spanglish blends with queers Lang as
drag queens take the center stage to the
Roar of the crowd
here there's Unapologetic invention in
creativity
it is not only a mix of two languages
but a constructing a shaping of new
words to reflect our own bodies Our Own
gender the ways that we come together
here you don't have to be a man or a
woman you don't have to be gay or
straight
here the categories for gender are
infinite as are the words to describe
body parts sexual orientation feelings
hear language let her hair down
Gloria Trevi plays in the background as
the next drag queen gets introduced as a
non-binary Fame that a mermaid of the
revolution
we all snap our fingers get it Mommy
I stand next to someone with hot pink
hair and a t-shirt that reads
genderqueer cyborg
Boys in crop tops yell yes
up and down twirling on the Dance Floor
serve someone says bring it someone
responds Essa wheel Roar
we were glitter on our bodies and
glitter on our language
we feel seen
our realities take up space and
therefore we experience a sense of
belonging
we feel this alone connected we add a
sense of magic and possibility to the
world we make it less boring and more
inviting
now
think of the ways that you speak the
words that you use
think of if you have borrowed words from
your parents your friends this is how
you know you belong to the circles right
by echoing back that language
the place where you grow up shows up in
your accent how you punctuate how you
use your bowels this is your very own
language wardrobe
each one of us has a different wardrobe
depending on our background our
ethnicity our access to education or
immigration status the places that we
come from
now consider how some of the most
glittery the most creative language
wardrobes are raised stigmatized or only
seen as spectacles
but what if alongside the language
wardrobe we see and hear every day we
also allowed for the freaky the weird
the ones that we don't understand
but in our world would be that much more
interesting
wouldn't our notion of what he means to
be human expand
what would happen if there's different
ways of using language of mixing English
with other languages of making up words
we're not considered less than but
instead manifestations of creative
brilliance
people are after all inventing creating
mixing
what would happen if for instance we
didn't see English as Spanish as
mutually exclusive as two separate
languages but as Open Circles touching
each other
imagine legislation written in Spanglish
or traffic signs written in queers Lang
Men At Work
[Music]
[Applause]
imagine textbooks where children also
learn words such as genderqueer and
queen where they'll learn how to write
it
that playfulness will seep into our own
lives lighten our worlds maybe we would
treat each other better
our daily interactions Will Be Kinder
less uncomfortable and fearful around
those who speak differently let's
isolating a damaging for those of us on
the margins
I want to invite us to suspend the idea
of a correct way of speaking a correct
way of using language and let's allow
for those rhythms those incorrect words
are the margins to rise up let's listen
recognize the glitter in each other's
way of speaking activate that kid at the
dining table who is in ah and curious
about language and its world
that child listening to her death drop
their eye my goodness as they drop their
aha baby kampaka
their endless possibility to bring
surprise and Magic through language
let's dance with language
let's tune into the ways that each one
of us speaks the many different ways
that each one of us make sense of the
world thank you
[Applause]